all right joy
yeah joy uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm from ohio
state in ohio
and tell me about your family and your
childhood you had both with your parents
when you were a kid
yeah uh well i started out living with
my grandmother who i thought was my mom
until she died
then i started living with my mom who i
thought was my cousin
um from then 4 to 17 i was molested
on a daily basis three family members a
pastor
i got married pastor as well yeah
i got married had two children by a
married man
um that ended
then i got married again this was a real
sub
type of guy real penitentiary type
and i thought he was a big dope dealer
and i was fascinated with just
his lifestyle but then i found out
he had a big habit
to crack and he had relapsed
and he didn't tell me none of that so
i found out he was doing all kinds of
stuff to get his though
but he was on a down low that was the
ultimate
um so he was
dating guys as well as or having sex
with guys he gave money
big money oh he's getting paid for it oh
yeah all right
and um so i asked him for my money back
because i was the type of woman you know
any money that came to me working
social security or whatever i would give
to my man
and uh i wanted to leave he didn't want
me to leave he wanted to tell the truth
but i have found out so i didn't want to
know the truth
whatever he called the truth and so
he gave me his dope he took he took dope
out hit the dope
made a pipe just amazed me
and um and offered it to me and just was
stuck
and i got upset took it and called
myself gonna just
smoke it up smoke it up you know that
way ain't got no dope left he won't have
no money you know anything
little did i know two weeks later i was
chasing the same [ __ ]
and it's been since 2000 that i've been
struggling
i'm at my lowest today i know
i'm literally homeless
[Music]
and i'm doing any and everything it's
about
that's mystery what kind of stuff do you
have to go through just to make money
still
sell my body
negotiate my morals
and it's not always for dope sometimes
it's to eat
sometimes just to um have a roof over my
head
even if it's just a tent
don't just be forgotten
and i'll just be for dope maybe for
everything i'm living to use and i'm
using to live
that's a mystery do you have children
they're two it's two they're grown
you have the two kids that you had with
the married man yeah
you raised them no my daughter stayed
with my sister
up until the addiction started happening
but my son was a ride or die today
my son was with me to the very end he
just
he had to let me go because i kept
getting us in predicaments where we
had to move had to move had to move
and at one point i didn't find a place
soon enough so he needed to stay with my
parents and
you know the anger started and since
then have you ever used drugs before
your
husband it was just that one
that one time got you hooked i was 37
years old
when i started when that happened
you haven't been able to stop since i
had like two or three years
um a couple of times
but it's what i choose you relapse
that's what i choose what do you think
people don't understand about the power
of crap or or addiction that is really
uh
a disease it's really a disease
it's not a decision you're making no
it's not a moment you start off making a
decision
yeah the first time is maybe a decision
but after that it becomes
beyond your power you know what happened
there are times when i can go like shoot
maybe two or three months and i'm cool
i'm cool and all of a sudden i can get a
urge that's beyond the phenomenon of
craving and
the obsession that i mean is beyond it
it's beyond it it's like um
i got to do anything so i've been going
to mental hospitals too because
i get to thinking about suicide because
i'm tired of living
dirty and nasty and secretive and
i'm tired of being alive that
and put down
do you have any friends i just met one
that i had a long time ago
in compton he's really old
and i didn't know where he had went you
know
and i just seen him it's been maybe
three years now
he said he got an apartment through the
va and in whittier
so he's offered me to take a shower and
eat and
lay down and get some rest so that's who
i was talking to when i was across the
street
where do you sleep like where did you
sleep last night
last night at the church i go to
churches that
is pretty lit up and have security
because they are
huge the one where farrah fawcett
funeral was the real big one
but it's scary anywhere
what kind of bad stuff has happened to
you out here
the robin the um
just having you do the sexual acts and
not paying you the money
throwing you out of a car throwing you
out of a car
um light on
then after a few weeks of this the shame
becomes
another thing that makes you use more
and the guilt yeah
do you have hope of getting getting out
permanently i feel like if
there is
a way they're not happy but i'm not
trying to make it happen no more
because i can't do anything i can't do
for me
what i feel like only god can do and i
feel like god is saying
um until um i could say no
this is a decision i gotta make and i
gotta stick to it
i mean he can keep me but i gotta wanna
be kept
and i'm not there yet
what's the most important lesson do you
think you've learned in your life
don't judge people
because i called my husband up a
crackhead home
and that's what i began
and now i understand
would you describe yourself as depressed
yeah i'm many depressed because i'm mad
because i understand so i don't have any
more excuses
so that makes me um that makes me angry
so when i do drugs um i don't feel
anything
i know it you know because our problems
don't go nowhere
they don't be waiting on us they be
right in the hit
you know so
and you were you were good friends with
one of my favorite
yeah people i've interviewed right
alicia
yeah did you guys used to talk about
your addiction
yeah we was in the same room in uh the
wine guard
and um it's like you know people just
allowing things to happen
um because they're smoking and
everything in the wine garden
i mean and the caseworkers and so forth
no
but for a woman who's addicted to crack
you end up
you're at the mercy of these men down
here that will just do
everything and anything right anything
they don't care about aids they don't
care about
pregnancies they don't care about black
eyes or broken bones
and most of them are down though yeah
most of
and they've taken out stuff on women
because they're not a woman
and they feel like we're stupid because
if we knew
how to uh work this we would
but no because what you're doing
is what we're doing it's just a
different way
and that's the problem because they
feeling you know raped and robbed
of their souls you know a lot of them
were taken advantage of
but um the um
the um the rage the vengeance is on the
wrong people
so yeah
a lot of times you get really bad
because they can see in your eyes
that you can see them behind the film
what was the best best part of your life
best time of your life when i was
about seven in the second grade when we
moved here
before the lesson started here
in california i want a contest
for safety how you keep your keys safe
so he gave me his brave big old trophy
that was probably the biggest me that
was in the shape of a key
my teacher cared so i wanted to be a
teacher
do you think that the uh the sexual
abuse you had
from those four different people when
you were very young
may have changed the course of your life
oh yeah
because my mom and people knew and it
was like they were
allowing us to be just passed around
your parents knew my mom
but then i found out my mom was going
through a lot of incest and had been
raped a lot and
had a lot of illegal abortions and
by her uncles and she told me she didn't
know how to help me
she learned how to block it out she
thought i would
yeah if you could have changed one thing
about your
your life what would you what would you
what would i change what would you
change my choice
to use yeah yeah
all right joy well thank you for coming
in and talking with me thank you
good luck getting clean i hope you turn
the corner on this
one day when you're done you'll be done
and you just
turn your back and move on thank you man
my tears are drying up i almost can't
even cry no more
i had moments you know i might get
i want to come back but i can't cry no
more a lot
let me get you a room tonight at least
what yeah
oh my god you sleep on the street
i can't do that wow
thank you
and a friend of alicia's how can i not
take care of her
oh my god oh my god
yes oh my god thank you
thank you thank you
you're about to remind me of her yeah
some daisy dips with some booze
at least she was great thank you so much
you have a great day you too thank you